hello my friends bodrum is a me server
who Palais des Festivals day long the
festival of languages I know they call
it a North American sim polyglot
symposium and there's going to be a lot
of interesting presentations on
different aspects of languages but most
of all there are going to be people who
learn languages who like learning
languages who know how to learn
languages and so everyone who's
interested in languages should go there
down like home field amore I love apple
a day long come on up on a lead on a
commercial day long so if you are
interested in languages and I never meet
anyone who isn't you know when I say
that I'm involved with languages people
say gee I'd like to learn this or that
language but a lot of people don't know
what's involved and actually it takes a
fair amount of time but it's also a
matter of knowing how I meet these
people all the time so if you are
interested in languages see was c70 I
still on yes an imitator show you and
your sink you what oh don't be Roy emons
I da da da Tama there's I don't wanna
tamaha you any seeing you doctor come
and put it out so much here so [ __ ]
light on da mondal ER jeg ER shathe
Gemma Uganda nega da we ok it's an
opportunity Seikichi ovation said said
you know Cassie o cirhonk o que entre mi
todo long hair p come on dear come on
viola if / if it's a public morale a
polyglot swap office unit you know
there's a whole group of people on the
internet who have helped me and
hopefully I've held some other people
there's a whole community of people that
are helping each other learn languages
and a lot of those people are going to
be in Montreal July 23rd 24th levante y
venkat VA a gr CH the Sun ashes aha
xiamen delay our pH idea ok we'll see
you there bye